I'll be honest with you I have no idea
what pose I'm doing in the thumbnail of
this video all I know is it's not this
and that makes it different whatever I
think yes it's time for my Wonder Woman
spoiler talk this is me talking about
the spoilers in the movie Wonder Woman
you haven't seen Wonder Woman do not
worry I have a spoiler free review I
will link it below so you can go check
it out check the movie out after you
watch the movie come back here you can
hear me prattle on about some spoilers
or we don't care about spoilers stick
around I love you so as this is a
spoiler talk spoilers ultimately come
along later on in the movie it's over
the part Wonder Woman follow Steve
Trevor to London because she needs to
stop world war 1 because she believes
Ares the God of War is behind World War
1 that's right Ares dict / Kratos now
he's [ __ ] over the earth dude he's
just a douche in everything separate
Brian has a relative under woman in
which he was a frail old broken man
other than that though and in following
Steve Trevor around she has a couple of
moments where she's like yeah what
you're saying is stupid guys like that
room or only dudes can be in it and she
just pops up and she was like why on
earth are you doing this she goes to
Steve Trevor she's like you didn't do
anything in there I love that because
that's very applicable to really the
working world in general it really
showed how she sees war it shows her
that this world she's stepped into it's
not what she came from and she plays
along with it with Steve Trevor like oh
we got to go to the mission until that's
seen on the battlefield she's like no
she puts on her tr and she's like that's
not what I'm going to do he goes out
there and she takes all the fire with
her shield no like she's taking the fire
let's do it they take the town guy she
was bad as an Esme no secrecy just
ghosts that dude is doing the Kino he's
being the sniper he's doing the Saving
Private Ryan thing they can't get a shot
opportunity I have just needs the whole
building the top of it comes down like
it's over I'm pretty sure that dude's
dead I had a fair amount intrigue as to
who is Ares for a while you think it's
that that dude we'll call him so Ares or
William Stryker from x-men Hurston's
Wolverine boys she thinks he's areas at
this point you think he's areas because
that doctor poison lady's giving him
these pills he inhales the gas and he
gets all jacked up I cannot help but
think looking forward what that might be
keeping in mind this is a cinematic
universe they are building we can't help
but think that might be a prelude to
Bane's venom
I can see Bane in a Batman movie down
the line I like the compound though I'm
from a doctor from World War one doctor
he probably would sound different
everything Incredible Hulk like Colonel
Ross is talking to Tim Roth
go back in World War two we tried
something new Tim Roth is like yeah
super soldier he's like over
simplification but yes and if you know
what you're listening for and looking at
you're like they're talking about
Captain America which is a cool easter
egg I can't help but think that little
pill that he would crack and smell like
roid rage smelling salt is Bane's venom
in some way shape or form it would Jack
him up and she kills him and the war is
not over and as I was supposed to be
dammit you kill Aries the war ends and
there's great dialogue between her and
Chris Pine at this point because pints
like maybe it's not that which I love
because for a long time Chris pints like
trees isn't real but he has a great bit
of dialogue with her he's like maybe
maybe it's not a god maybe this is just
us maybe we suck maybe there's good in
us in the human race but maybe there's
also shitty sucky that makes war maybe
that's just who we are and then Ares
comes out to validate the entire thing
that's right Remus Lupin one of Harry
Potter's great Guardians is like yep I'm
Ares and you guys do suck even says I'm
not the God of War I'm the god of
inspiration or something like that and I
was like wait gods have been aren't
those muses that's a muse right Ares is
a muse that's an e-tag it's an
interesting and relevant take as I love
that fact although the fact that it's
just whispers it's kind of like it's the
devil again most stories involving the
devil the devil always professes he's
like I don't make people do [ __ ] I just
said to stay drink in Hades there's the
god of the underworld so he is more
comparable to the devil doesn't change
the fact that Ares in this movies
tactics is very much that of the devil
in most stories whisper things the
people give them inspiration they will
do with it what they will which is
probably going to be very power hungry
and shitty but that poison lady with a
porcelain face she does serve a purpose
but really the villains in this movie
are very underdeveloped which I will say
is it just got a look at it for what it
is most some Marvel movies are great and
most the Marvel movies have a common
complaint and that is the villains are
very underdeveloped and now Wonder Woman
a DC movie in the DC Cinematic Universe
that many people profess is their
favorite in the DC Cinematic Universe
the villains are underdeveloped and in
that the point is I get it I myself
would like to find some Goldilocks zone
where it's like great heroes story with
a great villain everything worked you
cannot deny concentrating on the heroes
works for a better movie overall if you
just have to choose one I just found
that interesting I really did because in
a movie about
heroes if the villain takes a hit the
hero can still shine if the hero takes a
hit why are we here let's see where
Wonder Woman is holding that tank up in
Aries is like yeah smasher crusher she's
a dick I like that moment watches Wonder
Woman looks at her and she's like that
she's just she's broken and she is
undeniably [ __ ] up in her methodology
but really she is a victim of you
[ __ ] oh no I did like Steve Trevor's
sacrifice it gets a little heavy-handed
with the love thing you know he gives
her a watch and he's like I Love You
Missy has her monologue basically
validating Gary Potter
she's like a love is old magic it is a
strongest thing ever that did make me
good at is you rising the cheese but
when Steve Trevor takes the plane up and
he aims his gun I'm like okay don't just
pull the trigger and have it blow up
have a moment take a breath slow down
for a second because Chris Pine was a
shining character in this Wonder Woman
movie do we be ashamed spill
accomplisher enough he does it takes the
prize it takes a moment that's all I
needed then he shoots blows it up
sacrifices themselves in Wonder Woman
ultimately I guess finds her confidence
see the sword is not the god killers
tries to stab Aries with the diffuser
turns to ashes like now you're the god
killer Zeus that dude God around you are
one of his kids basically you were
created to stop me one day and then she
does she's kind of all right deflect
deflect not you're not going to hurt
anyone anymore
and then she's out she doesn't say that
there's people out there like whoa she
has powers of shazam deceit no she
doesn't is the word I'd use just now
ultimately she just vaporizes in now
that's what I talked about my spoiler
free review or I was like the ending
doesn't come across it's a bit easy like
struggle struggle struggle you know what
no problem at all
it actually surprisingly makes me want
to watch Batman vs Superman now when you
look at Batman vs Superman you're like
Oh Wonder Woman comes into that after
she did all of this [ __ ] I want to see
the next chapter I want to see what she
does next and if what she does next is
Batman vs Superman kind of want to see
that now maybe that was their master
plan all along going yeah we're not
going to have the individual movies
before the big P Mouse you can have the
big team-up then watch the individual
movies you're you be like ooh now I want
to see what they did in the team up
after I'm now wearing the lenses of
seeing their individual movies so
there's an eighth replay value I don't
know all I know is there seems to be a
bit of a causality here and in the end
Wonder Woman did what I wanted it to do
brother
did what I was hoping you would do a
kick-ass movie in the DC Cinematic
Universe and hopefully shows everybody
that there is a pulse in the DC
Cinematic Universe but everyone want to
know what you think about it so Wonder
Woman have you seen it what did you
think about it and what were your
favorite and least favorite parts
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]